[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حلقه جديده من برنامج من
المصدر المخصص هذا الاسبوع للذكرى الاولى
لاندلاع الحربي في اوكرانيا
عام على الحرب في اوكرانيا بخطبين
متناقضين نشرح المشهد الاعلامي للحرب من
استدرج الاخر بوتين وناقش نائبا اوكرانيا
ودبلوماسيا روسيا ايران الحاضر الغائب في
حرب اوكرانيا رغم الضجيج حول ضلوعها في
تزويد روسيا بالمسيرات المغازله الغربيه
لدفعها لاحياء الاتفاق النووي لا تتوقف
صداع موازن يشتعل على مواقع التواصل بين
طرفي النزاع يفتح عصر الحروب الهجينه كيف
تتصدى كياب لحرب المعلومات الروسيه
[موسيقى]
قبل عام من الان باغه الرئيس بوتين العالم
في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير بالاعلان عن
عمليات عسكريه موسعه في اوكرانيا وذلك في
كلمه متلفزه بثها بالتزامن مع انعقاد
الجلسه امميه في نيويورك لمطالبته بالتوقف
عن التصعيد اعلاميا وعسكريا عبر حشد قواته
على الحدود الاوكرانيه ومنذ ذلك الحين
انقسم المشهد الاعلامي بين جويتين حول
اسباب الانزلاق الى الحرب وتين في كلمته
وقتها قال ان العمليه العسكريه تهدف الى
حمايه المدنيين من الاعتداءات الاوكرانيه
في مقاطعتي
اللتان اعلن الاعتراف باستقلالهما قبل
يومين من بدء الهجوم لتتبلورات في الاعلام
المحلي بان الحرب اتت ردا على اعتداءات
النازيين والمتطرفين من الاوكرانيين
المتحالفين مع الغرب وكانت
قبلها طبعا طبول الحرب تقرع والتحذيرات
الغربيه تتصاعد من الحرب الذي اختار بوتين
ان يخوضها من دون مبرر وفق الروايه
الامريكيه والغنيه
ولكن بالنسبه الى روسيا الخطر داهم
القنوات الروسيه اظهرت فيديوهات عن تحرشات
واعتداءات عسكريه اوكرانيه في المناطق
الواقعه تحت سيطره النفوذ الروسي في خرق
واضح لاتفاقيه المسك التي تنص على سحب
السلاح الثقيل من المنطقه وكاله الروسيه
كما نرى هنا تقول في الحادي والعشرين من
فبراير 2022 ان الجيش الروسي والقوات
الانفصاليه التابعه لروسيا تصدت لمجموعه
لمجموعه تخريب اوكرانيه وعرضت الوكاله
سلسله الاعتداءات بالتواريخ للقوات
الاوكرانيه كما بثت القنوات الروسيه مقاطع
فيديو لما وصفته دخول مخربين الى الاراضي
الخاضعه لروسيا هجوم عسكري على المدني
سارعت غياب والاعلام الغربي الى ضحضه الكا
الروايه خاصه بالنسبه الى الروايه حول
استهداف حضانه اطفال حيث تبادل الجانبان
الاتهامات بشانها
استعاد التلفزيون روسيا مشاهد انتصار
ستالينغراد على النازيين فبالنسبه لروسيا
الحرب العالميه الثانيه الحرب الوطنيه
العظمى كما يسميها الروس وتحاكي اوكرانيا
اليوم لطرد النازيين والانتصار عليهم خطاب
لشد العصب الوطني ضد الغرب مستعيدا سرديه
الحرب البارده يعمل بوتين ومن حوله مباشره
على تعبئه الروس على الجبهه الداخليه
والتلاعب في وجهات النظر العامه للغزو في
الخارج لقد نجح في بعض النواحي في حرب
المعلومات هذه وفق التحليلات الغربيه
كتبت بعد مرور عام ان الحرب في اوكرانيا
اظهرت ان معتقدات بوتين ومحيطه لا تزال
متاثره بالخطاب السوفيتي المعادي للغرب
الصحيفه قالت ان هدف بوتين لا يزال العوده
للتسويه التي تم تحقيقها عام
عندما جالس الرئيس الامريكي
والرئيس الوزراء البريطور على الطاوله
امام الزعيم السوفيتي جوزيف ستالين وقبل
هيمنه موسكو بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
على اوروبا الشرقيه
التجيش الاعلامي ضد اوكرانيا اتى في سياق
التذكير بحكومه زيلينسكي التي تسعى الى
الدخول الى حلف الناتو وبالتالي تهديد
روسيا وهنا بيت القصيد ومع تسارع الاحداث
والاتهامات التي تؤذن باقتراب ساعه الصفر
سارع الغرب باعلانه لابلاغ بوتين ان دخول
اوكرانيا للناتو ليس ورتيكا كما تتمنى
وتضغط كياف
كتبت لهذه الاسباب حلف الناتو لن يسمح
لاوكرانيا دخوله قريبا ونقلت الصحيفه
الامريكيه بان الرئيس بايدن والقاده
الاوروبيين ليسوا مستعدين لهذه الخطوه
صعد الغرب بقياده امريكا موقفه ضد الحرب
لكنه في نفس الوقت ابقى الباب مواربا
لبوتين للتحرك في ظل تاكيد حلف الناتو عدم
دخوله في حرب مباشره مع بوتين ونتذكر
حينما قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن عشيه
الحرب ان تحرك الغرب سياتي بناء على حجم
الغزو الروسي موقف اعتبره كثيرون كاذن
دخول وقت
حصلت الحرب بتكلفه بشريه واقتصاديه باهظه
وصلت ارتداداتها الى العالم اجمع هذا فيما
اقر مسؤول بايدن بان الولايات المتحده
رفضت الجزمه في قضيه انضمام اوكرانيا الى
حلف شمال اطلسي قبل الغزو الروسي ما اكد
ركوب كثيرين بان اداره بايدن لم تفعل ما
يكفي بما في ذلك تاكيد الرفض او تاخير
عضويه اوكرانيا في الناتو لمنع روسيا من
شنها حرب ضد اوكرانيا وافقه بان ارم
ومؤخرا قبيل زياره بايدن الى اوكرانيا
لاظهار دعمه لكياب توجه احد الصحفيين
الامريكيين في البيت الابيض بالاسئله
التاليه الى المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي جون كوربي كيف لم تتفهم واشنطن
مخاوف توسع الناتو شرقا كيف يمكن لروسيا
ان تصدق ان الناتو الذي نصب الاتحاد
السوفيتي العداء لمده 50 عاما هو حلف
دفاعي اليس من الصواب القول ان الناتو هو
من تحرك شرقا نحو روسيا وليس روسيا من
تحركت غربا نحو النيتو نتواصل
وفي هذا السياق تقول راغده درغام
اراد خلطه الاوراق والمساومات على نظام
عالمي جديد خاصه بعد اظهار امريكا ضعفها
في مشهد الانسحاب من افغانستان ووجد الغرب
له بالمرصاد ولعل الغرب اوقعه في الورطه
دول حلف الناتو كانت تدرك تماما معنى
كلامها عن ادخال اوكرانيا عضوا في الحلف
ومدى استفزاز مثل هذه الاجراءات لروسيا
كما للمعادله العسكريه بين الغرب وروسيا
فعلت ما فعلته عمدا وليس سهوا واشبهت
الكاتبه ورطت الرئيس بوتين في اوكرانيا
بواسطه صدام حسين في الكويت مع الفارق ان
بوتين رئيس دوله نوويه وبالتالي لديه
ادوات لازال بامكانه استخدامها
واليوم نسال الدبلوماسيروسيل السابق
الكساوند اهلا بك سعاده السفير نرى اليوم
ان روسيا تدفع ثمنا واهظا سياسيا وعسكريا
واقتصاديا بفعل العقوبات الاقتصاديه
والماليه والتكنولوجيه عليها كيف يقيم
المواطنون نتائج الحرب هل انزلقت روسيا
الى الفخ كما يقول البعض اهلا بك
هذه المعركه
معركه وجود روسيه
فلذلك السؤال ليس مطروح امامك عن روسيا
تدفع ثمنا بل نحن نعرف ان هناك الخطه
الغربيه
لتضمير روسيه
والاستلاع على مواردها
مواجهه تجري ما بين روسيا والغرب قياده
امريكا واوكرانيا هي فقط صاحت لهذا لهذا
الصراع
والي نحن في
بعض صنع من بدايه
العمليه العسكريه ونحن وسط الطريق لا يمكن
اليوم ان نتحدث عن نتائج لهذه المعركه
لانه
[موسيقى]
الاشتباكات تجري
متى ستنتهي وكيف وما هي تكون فنحن لا نعرف
لكن هل كان هناك خطر فعلي على روسيا هل
اوكرانيا تشكل هذا الخطر الداهم على روسيا
لكي تبدا هذه العمليه العسكريه او الحرب
على اوكرانيا
الله نحن نعود الى سنه 14
عندما حصل
انقلاب في كيف وجعني نظام جديد
نظام ناجي على الذي بضع الحرب في دون باص
وخلال ثمانيه سنوات هناك الله قصف
الاوكراني
لمنطقه دنباص فعمليه العسكريه روسيه اصبحت
جوابا على هذه الحرب الطويله نعم الغرب
كما يبدو مصمما على الحرب ما قد يعرض
روسيا الى الاستنزاف في المدى البعيد
وازدياد الضغوط الداخليه لانهاء الحرب مثل
ما قلنا انه
لا توجد خيارات اخرى الا الصمود في وجه
التمدد نعطوه والهجوم والغربي عبر
اوكرانيا
فبالتالي
هم يريدون هزيم
لروسيا نحن نريد انتصار روسيا في اوكرانيا
البعض يقول ان المنتصر في الحرب هو حقيقه
حلف الناتو الذي ازداد قوه وتوسعا وتعاضضا
ومعه اوكرانيا يعني اتت بنتائج عكسيه هذه
الحرب
الشنق لاوانه يا ان نتحدث كما قلت
عن
النتيجه
لهذه الخرا لانه
نحن لا نزال في وسط المعركه
الصين تقول ان لديها مبادره للحل معقول
التي ترضى به روسيا ما هي يعني ابرز
البنود التي ممكن ان تقبل بها روسيا
لانهاء هذه الحرب مرارا وتكرارا روسيا
تتكون اوكرانيا خطرا لروسيا في المستقبل
هل ممكن لروسيا اليوم ان تنسحب من جميع
الاراضي التي دخلتها من خلال تسويه ما لا
هذا هذا كليا حتى هناك هذه اربع مناطق
الجديده روسيه
عدم مسجل في دستور انه هي اصبحت جزء لا
يتجزا من روسيا فلذلك
اي تفاوض ممكن ان يكون
بشروط انه
الروسي اراضي روسيه بما
الاراضي جديده
الدبلوماسي الروسي السابق الكونسيس بكين
شكرا جزيلا لك
على كل حال اصدر الستار على السنه الاولى
من الحرب بخطبين ببايدن في وارسو وبوتين
في موسكو اظهرها خلالهما عزيمه اكبر
لمواصله الحرب حتى الانتصار وبتصلب اكثر
في مواقفهما وقل طرف لام الاخر في الدفع
الى اتون الحرب التي لم يكن يريدها ما
اظهر جليا اتساعا هو بين الجانبين وما
يؤشر الى ان امد الحرب لن ينتهي قريبا
نسال النائب في البرلمان الاوكراني الذي
اشتهر على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بسبب
مواقفه الحاده ضد روسيا اوليكسي جون
شارينكو الخطاب الروسي كما جاء على لسان
الرئيس بوتين في كلمته الاخيره ان الغرب
هو من افتعل الحرب عبر تهديد روسيا ما
رايك اهلا بكم
يكذب كما اعتاد دائما اود ان اذكرك بانه
اصدر تصريحات على مدى شهور طويله قال فيها
انه لا ليت لديه لغزو اوكرانيا وانما كان
يجري كان مجرد مناورات عسكريه تلك كانت
اكذوبه وها هو اليوم يعاود الكذب الذي لم
يفارقه البته لانه يكذب 24 ساعه في اليوم
وطيله ايام الاسبوع
لكن رئيس في خطابه يقول انه سعى لتفادي
الحرب اي رئيس بوتين عائله تفادي الحرب
لكن الغرب ارادها يتحدث هنا في اطار طرح
فكره ضم اوكرانيا الى حلف الناتو ما رايك
ما دفعه لشن الحرب هو نظرته لاوكرانيا
التي لطالما اعتبرها مستعمره تابعه لهم
هذا كل ما في الامر والحرب التي تدور
راحاها حاليا هي حرب استعماريه تشن ضد
اوكرانيا وهو يحاول تبريرها مستخدما
اعذارا سخيفه لان اوكرانيا لم تكن عضوا في
حلف الناتو في الماضي وهي ليست عضوا فيه
اليوم ولم تسعى اوكرانيا قبل بدء هذه
الحرب وكذلك قبل عام 2014 ان تنضم الى
عضويه الحلف لكن بعد شن روسيا حربها على
اوكرانيا اصبحنا نريد اليوم ان نكون عضوا
في النيتو من اجل الحصول على ضمانات امنيه
هذه هي حقيقه الامور اليوم وما قاله بوتين
مؤخرا كان كاذبا اضافيا
لان اوكرانيا لم تكن عضوا في النيتو ولم
يكن اي طرف بعسكرتها وعندما بدا
استعداداته للغزو وعندما حصل الغزو فعلا
عندئذ فقط بدانا بتلقي دعم عسكري هائل من
قبل حلفائنا انه هو من تسبب بعسكره
اوكرانيا بعد ان اقدم على غزوها ما هو
الحل الواقع الان بنظركم لانهاء الحرب في
ظل التحرك الصيني
يجب ان يرحل عن اراضينا هذا كل ما نريده
نحن لا نريد الحصول على شبر واحد من
الاراضي الروسيه عليه ان يوقف عدوانه
وينسحب من بلادنا
بحل واقعي وقال انه لا يجب اهانه
قال ذلك لكنه قال ايضا ينبغي على اوكرانيا
ان تنتصر في الحرب ويصعب علي فهم مساله
الاهانه لان المجرمين لا يجب اهانتهم
وانما معاقبتهم وبوتين مجرم حرب دوليه
الامر لا يتعلق بالاهانه بل باستعاده
النظام الدولي لانه يتعين احترام مبدا
السياده واذا تمكن بوتين من مهاجمه دوله
ذات سياده فان اي شخص اخر في العالم يكون
قادرا على القيام بما قام به بوتين عندئذ
كيف سيكون حال العالم سيكون الوضع كارثيا
استاذ اريد ان انهي معك بسؤال عن ايران
هذا الملف سنتناوله في الجزء الثاني من
الحلقه نسالك سعاده
النائبنكو الذي يجوب العالم للدفاع عن
قضيه بلاده كيف هي علاقتكم الان مع ايران
وكيف تقراون الموقف الامريكي
وهي حليف لروسيا التي قدمت لها اسلحه تشمل
المسيرات لقتل الاوكرانيين لا توجد اي
علاقه تربطنا بايران والنظام الايراني
نظام شرير يتعين تدميره لماذا اعلق على
قرارات تتخذها الولايات المتحده الامر
يعود لهم لتبني النهج الذي يرونه مناسبا
للتعامل مع ايران النائب في البرلمان
الاوكراني اوليك كن شارينكو شكرا جزيلا لك
بعد الفاصل رغم الحظر الاوروبي على
الاعلام الروسي كيف يتنامى وجوده في
الشارع الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
من جديد ثاني الملاحظات البارزه التي شدت
الانتباه في السنه الاولى من حرب اوكرانيا
هي الدور الايراني بعد توافر الادله على
ضلوع طهران فيها الى جانب روسيا هذا
التحالف الذي يصفه الغربي تحالف المصالح
وفقورن بدا يقلق الغرب بشكل متصاعد هذا
التحالف الذي كان مقبولا نوعا ما في سوريا
اصبح مزعجا عندما انتقل الى اوكرانيا
وتحديدا في يوليو الماضي عندما اعلن
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيكس ان
ايران تستعد لارسال مئات المسيرات لتوسيا
توالت التقارير الاعلاميه الغربيه وخاصه
في منتصف اغسطس عن وصول اول شحنه من
المسيرات الايرانيه الى روسيا واشنطن بوست
وهي من نوع شاهد ومهاجر مسيرات صغيره
وبسيطه لكنها قادره على استهداف البندل
الاوكرانيه والبنيه التحتيه الحيويه فيها
سبتمبر بدانا نرى مسيرات تمطر المدن
الاوكرانيه متسببه باضرار بشريه وماديه
جسيمه وعلى وقعها تعاظمت الادله التي
قدمتها ثياب علنا عن طلوع ايران في الحرب
على اوكرانيا
كانت ذروه تلك الهجمات بالمسيرات حصلت في
اكتوبر لكن استمرت ايران بالنفي علاقتها
بالموضوع واستمر الاعلام الايراني بنشر
بيانات النفي فكيف يمكن لدوله كايران التي
تدعو الى الحياد الايجابي والسلام بين
الدول ان تفعل ذلك وفق كلام المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
للاسف يتم نشر اخبار تستند الى اهداف
سياسيه ويتم اثارتها بشكل اساسي من
المصادر الغربيه كما اعلن جمهوريه ايران
الاسلاميه عده مرات انها ليست طرفا في
الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا
حاول يزال يقد
م الاذبل بارسال خبراء عسكريين الى روسيا
لمساعده الروس على تجديد اوكرانيا اكبر
قدر من الاضرار رغم ادعاء طهران
وفي الخامس من نوفمبر 2022 ومع تعاظم
الادله ضدها خرج وزير الخارجيه الايراني
الى الاعلام للاعتراف وبرر ذلك بان صفقه
المسيرات مع روسيا تعود الى ما قبل الحرب
وان ايران ستعمل على ضمان عدم استخدام
روسيا لمسيراتها في الحرب فرد عليه الرئيس
الاوكراني بان ايران تكذب حتى في اعترافها
وكياب لديها ما يثبت تورط ايران الى جانب
روسيا في الحرب
تروج بعض الدول الغربيه ان جمهوريه ايران
الاسلاميه زودت روسيا بالصواريخ والطائرات
بدون طيار للمساعده في الحرب في اوكرانيا
الجزء المتعلق بالصواريخ خاطئ تماما جزء
الطائرات المسيره صحيح لقد زودنا روسيا
بعدد قليل من الطائرات المسيره قبل اشهر
من الحرب الولايات المتحده تحذر اليوم من
تحالف دفاعي كامل بين روسيا وايران
ونيويورك تايمز كشفت عن مرحله متطوره من
التعاون العسكري بين البلدين وافقت تقرير
تساعد روسيا طهران في تحديث قواتها الجويه
المتهالكه ما سيزيد من خطرها في زعزعه
استقرار العالم ايضا فان حصول نظام طهران
انظمه دفاع جويه روسيه متطوره سيجعلها
اكثر قدره على حمايه البنيه التحتيه
لسلاحها النووي المحتمل الذي ما زالت
القوى الغربيه والولايات المتحده تراوح
مكانها في اتخاذ موقف حاسم تجاهه كما حال
اتجاه سلوك ايران التوسعي في المنطقه
وفقهيمز ويكشف التقرير الصحيفه المستند
على تحليل صور الاقمار الصناعيه للفيديو
الذي بثته ايران عن قدراتها العسكريه وجود
مجسمات لطائرات صخور الروسيه المقاتله
التي من المتوقع ان تستلمها طهران خلال
اشهر ما سيمثلوا تطورا هائلا على مستوى
اسطول طائراتها المقاتله
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
من تكامل عسكري جاري بين البلدين والذي
سيقوض استقرار المنطقه والعالم واكد على
ضروره حظر الاسلحه لايران احتراما لقرار
مجلس الامن 2231
فرد عليه المسؤول السابق في الخارجات
الامريكيه عن الملف الايراني جابرييل
نورونها بالقول لا تنسى ان اداره بايدن هي
من رفعت قبل عام حظر الاسلحه على ايران
الذي كان يمنع تبادل الاسلحه بين موسكو
وطهران ومنذ ذلك الحين تنام التبادل
العسكري بين الجانبين بشكل كبير هذا فيما
كشفت صحيفه فريبيكن عن اعفاءات جديده
قدمتها اداره بايدن لايران تتصل ببرنامجها
النووي في مسعر جديد لاحياء الاتفاق
النووي
في الذكرى الاولى لاندلاع الحربي في
اوكرانيا اصبح هذا النزاع اول صراع هجين
يحدث على الارض بقدر ما يحدث في الفضاء
ويؤسس عصرا جديدا في الحروب التي اصبحت
تتطلب تدخل كل من العالمين العسكري
والاستخباراتي والمعلوماتي سويا
على صعيد التجيش الاعلامي زاد نشاط
الحسابات المشبوهه التي تحمل دعايه روسيه
بنسبه 3000% في شهرين نوفمبر وديسمبر 2021
مقارنه ببقيه العام اي قبل بدء المعارك
وفقا لدراسه اجرتها منصه ميثوس لاعب
المتخصصه في مكافحه المعلومات المضلله
وعلى صعيد الهجمات الالكترونيه اكبر هجوم
سايبراني روسي كان حصل بالتزامن مع حشد
القوات الروسيه على الحدود مع اوكرانيا
وقبل الهجوم بساعه بالضبط ادى هجوم
الكتروني الى شل خدماتي شركه فايروسات
الامريكيه المتخصصه في الاتصالات عبر
الاقمار الصناعيه وحرم العديد من الشركات
والخدمات العامه الاوكرانيه وايضا جيش
البلاد من الانترنت ثم انتشر الى العديد
من المستخدمين الاوروبيين
وما اعلن الحرب الروسيه تم تعيين ميخاله
فيدروب وزيرا للحرب من نوع جديد نائب رئيس
الوزراء ووزير التحول الرقمي في اوكرانيا
انشا على تطبيق تيليجرام قناه تضمه ما لا
يقل عن 30 الف شخص تحولوا الى جيش رقمي
وطني مشكل بالكامل من متطوعين وفي اليوم
الثاني من الحرب تبادل ميخالو بدروب مع
ايلون ماسك التفاعل على تويتر قارن بدراف
بين رغبه موس باستعمار المريخ فيما
اوكرانيا كانه تحت القصف مطالبا اياه
بتزيد اوكرانيا بمحطات ستارلينج وبعد
حوالي عشر ساعات اتى الرد من ماسك واعدا
بتوفير 1600 قمر صناعي في جميع انحاء
اوكرانيا وفي يناير قال رئيس خدمات الامن
السيبراني في اوكرانيا ان فراقه تمكنت من
تحييد 4500 هجوم الكترونيه منذ بدايه
الصراع لتصبح ثياب الدرع السيبراني للعالم
الغربي بفضل المهارات الاوكرانيه اضافه
الى مساهمه شركات دوليه مثل مايكروسوفت
وسيسكو
[موسيقى]
اخبار الاعلام طبعا اخترناها متصله بذكرى
الحربي في اوكرانيا قالت رئيسه تحرير
روسيا اليوم مارجريتا سيمونيان خلال
مقابله نادره لها مؤخرا انه رغم الحظر
الدولي على قناه روسيا اليوم فانها تصل
الى الجمهور الاوروبي عن طريق الاعلام
الاندروغرام او البديل او غير العلني
بدليل تنام الاراء الداعمه لروسيا وافقه
تعبيرها
ومع هذا نصل الى نهايه حلقتنا لليوم
موعدنا يتجدد الاسبوع المقبل شكرا لحسن
المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]